are you ready for over watches next hero
well we just got a look at her I'm Tony
this is a game spot news update and for
all the latest on overwatch be sure to
subscribe arisa is a tank hero built by
effets the young inventor Blizzard
teased in some earlier blog posts her
main weapon is a fusion driver in Auto
firing gun with great range that slows
her movement when used it also has an
alternate pulsefire that slows down
enemies it passes then draws them in
upon detonation arisa can also briefly
buff herself with super high defense and
throw down a protective barrier for her
teammates finally her ultimate is a
supercharger that boosts the attack
power of any teammate in its line of
sight in short arisa is all about
protecting others arisa is live right
now on blizzard's public test realm but
no full release date has been revealed
for more shooter news you can check out
our breakdown of escape from tarkov scab
faction and for all the latest on all
the shooters you're already in the right
place
[Music]